you own any crypto i do own a little bit
of crypto do i own any crypto yes
absolutely not why not
because i don't want my money to be
attached to the wi-fi password you guys
need crypto
cryptocurrency yeah negative negative
why not
son i'm a hood dude son i like my [ __ ]
in cash dogs
like a little ethereum that's gone down
about 25 since i bought it oh i got
hypebeast you a hypebeast you just got
all because everybody was on it
everybody was on it i heard
somebody talk about it at a show that's
all it took that's all it took you heard
somebody talk about it yeah if i would
have buried the money i'd have more
money i'm out of nerve so i don't know
what they doing with that crypto you
know what i mean i don't even know what
crypto means dog you got the homie
trying to put you on though yeah
everybody is it a trustworthy hobby
negative though it's always the worst
dude
it's always a dude yo if somebody's
telling you yo it's always like yo you
want to buy crypto or nave i'm like what
[ __ ] you can't be selling weed and
crypto
if you've watched any sports in the past
few months you may have noticed a couple
of important things about athletes
one
tom brady is the reason people have
trust issues
and two they're all lining up to shield
cryptocurrency
i'm thrilled to be announcing partnering
with ftx i can't tell you everything
we're going to leave
this is the bitcoin quarterback
challenge presented by cash up featuring
joe burrow first even if you wanted to
come back we wouldn't take you yes you
would yeah we would you're right we
would what's up i'm getting into crypto
yep tom brady's puckering up and
smooching the blockchain like it's a
reluctant sun
which is why today we're gonna talk
about cryptocurrency or as i like to
call it
funny money
and i'm not here to explain funny money
to you or tell you where you should put
your cash but what i do want to talk
about the game
the hustle because when i see all these
crypto advertisements and sports all i
can see is a lot of hustlers who think
they found their mark
you
remember super bowl sunday that's when
the griff really got cooking
super bowl 56 has been coined the crypto
bowl the crypto bowl crypto bulb crypto
bowl crypto bowl crypto bowl the crypto
bowl
look just because there was crypto in
the super bowl doesn't mean you can call
it the crypto bowl just like we can't
call the upcoming world cup in qatar the
slave cup
still
on super bowl sunday we were witnessing
something special the consummation of
the marriage between pro sports and the
crypto industry the staples center is
now crypto.com arena the miami heat
playing a building named for a crypto
exchange ftx arena and of course
athletes aren't just advertising for
crypto companies they're getting into
crypto themselves
we're getting more and more into the
crypto i have probably over like 30 to
33 different
crypto the richest people in the world
they are talking about it and they are
talking about having a certain portion
of their portfolio to reflect that are
you
yes
can i ask which currency
no
chris carter said no faster than the
hall of fame did to his nomination for
six straight
years my bad big homie
but no athlete and i mean no athlete has
gotten deeper into the blockchain game
than cowboys locker room legend dez
bryant
dez is the blockchain missionary among
athletes he's the joel osteen of
blockchain
and his pitch for how athletes can
monetize their brands is fairly
compelling
how do they monetize and digitize
their likeness their image their brand
see how you um how you monetize and how
you do that is um
um what you do is um
you know i
apologize i'm kind of nervous you know
um
it's early in the morning
hey
man it's cool i'd be nervous too if i
ain't know what i was talking about
but it's not just the players maybe you
saw the ftx logo last year on patches
worn by major league baseball umpires
yeah umpires
crypto companies use athletes to make
them seem cool and the [ __ ] baseball
cops to make them seem safe and
rule-bound
like something other than an orgy of
anarcho-capitalist grifters
con artists that means con artists
turns out crypto and sports really did
have a lot to offer each other the
leagues needed to raise capital having
lost billions of dollars in the pandemic
and there is a natural overlap between
sports fandom and crypto
even before the super bowl a poll found
that sports fans were about twice as
likely as non-fans to say they're
familiar with crypto there's no mystery
about why that is
crypto
is
gambling
sports fans have been prepared for the
crypto moments is basically the
invention of the point spread
i'll explain
crypto is a boom and bus industry people
call it currency but that's just the
word they use to keep the feds off the
scent crypto is a speculative asset
something you bet on like gold or fine
art or the ball brothers
you hope you pick the one that ends up
in the all-star game but you might end
up with the one shop lifting fake gucci
in china
liangelo to the moon
and the thing we know about sports
culture we love to speculate about the
future
and we are almost always wrong
if the houston texans pass on johnny
manziel they will forever regret it he's
like a marshawn lynch
with speed and elusiveness you could be
looking at a guy who's certainly one of
the elite top five quarterbacks in this
league yao is the old school ye is new
school he's hip-hop he's 50 cent he
loves to dunk on you
see
crypto culture is sports culture they're
both all about creating sustaining and
commodifying your hope and let's get
this straight i totally 100 understand
why cryptocurrency is a thing
people love to be in on the ground floor
something new
what could be
always more exciting than what is
especially if you ain't got that much
and crypto is at least theoretically
useful for people who can't access the
formal financial system or need to send
money overseas
whole damn country feels like a racket
anyway
no one trusts anyone or anything anymore
trusting once reliable institutions has
cratered
congress the fed
the huxtables
and so here's this new form of money
that seems to exist outside all these
institutions beyond the concept of trust
itself because who needs trust when
you've got digitally distributed ledgers
even if you just had to google what that
means
so of course people are into it we're
all on our own forsaken by god and state
and your local black gynecologist
that's what the crypto evangelist wants
you to think anyway there's a refrain
you hear in their world a lot
with anything you have to do your own
research and doing your own research
we're going to teach you how to do your
own research do your own
research
spike got me feeling like dap in school
days
[Music]
[Applause]
volatility is the whole ballgame the
choice between traditional investments
or putting your money in crypto is the
difference between planning a weekend
with tim duncan
or dennis rodman
tim duncan might be less exciting but
you won't end up breaking your dick in
three different ways
hey this is dennis rodman
let me show you how to break your dick
three ways
that clip actually goes on for 20 more
minutes
but you get the idea
now the federal government monitors
crypto to some degree what the feds
don't do is regulate celebrities hyping
cryptocurrency
and that's where this [ __ ] gets
insidious because these major athletes
promoting crypto the ones being turned
into the functional equivalent of casino
greeters more often than not
they have no [ __ ] clue what they're
talking about
please welcome to the stage floyd
[ __ ] mayweather
in this world you had pepsi you got coke
i mean you got different products so
everybody should
in
what i believe in just being independent
and doing what you want to do and it's
about people winning and winning in life
and i push people to be winners in life
because i'm a winner
what's craziest about floyd forking
mayweather's explanation is that he's
literally at the biggest crypto
conference in the world and he still
can't tell you the difference between an
nft or an std
and if you get either
you can get burnt
and who's out here giving people that
crypto clap floyd himself
floyd mayweather and dj producer khalid
settling fraud charges with the sec
over their initial coin offerings icos
the sec charging the pair for promoting
icos without disclosing payments both
men settled these charges without
admitting or denying any wrongdoing
yup
even when dj producer khaled is hyping
the coin he needs a more famous guest
feature
the legit crypto companies and their
prize athletes would at least warn you
about the risks involved with investing
in the blockchain just ask jimmy butler
and binance
on february the 13th some of the biggest
names are going to be telling you to get
into crypto binance and i we're here to
tell you trust yourself and do your own
research
all right now this is the most important
commercial of them all because even if
jimmy looks like he's your grandmama
facetiming you what he's saying here is
the whole cynical message of the crypto
sports complex distilled to its essence
you can't trust anyone
trust me
did you catch those magic words do your
own research because you know now that i
think about it i have definitely heard
that phrase in a lot of other contexts
go to websites do your own research stay
involved you should do your own research
don't take my word for any of it check
this out for yourself do your own
research i'm not a scientist i'm not
here to tell everyone that this is it
for me it's just um just giving everyone
a chance to do their own research
what does that look like
you're doing your own research
are you doing
studies yourself are you in the lab on a
nightly basis what are you doing
jess clinging to real expertise like
it's alonzo mourner's leg
but he gets it
do your own research is how you know the
hustle is on somebody says that [ __ ]
it's time to feel for your wallet
so get into crypto if you must sports
fans but know what you're doing you're
not making an end run on self-interested
experts and elites you're subbing out
one set of experts and elites for
another jamie dimon for trevor lawrence
george bank for dez bryant jerome powell
who's not as black as he sounds for some
guy calling himself bitcoin jesus
we all like stats right well here's a
good one the top point zero one percent
control 27 of the bitcoin in circulation
right now
you're putting your money where a lot of
very rich people are telling you to put
it
what good ever came of that
and now
a word from an athlete you can trust
who's pitching a more
conservative approach
hi my name is meta world peace you may
know me from my nba days as someone
who's not afraid of taking some chances
but off the court i couldn't be more
risk adverse in fact the only teas i'm
getting these days are t-bonds the
20-year treasury bond has an average
rate of return of 2.5 percent per year
now i know what you're thinking meta i
can get a 6.6 annual return with a
traditional 401k or a roth ira if my
projected income at retirement will be
higher but those have contribution caps
trust me t-bonds are the way to go babe
can i get you a nice cool glass of milk
what's the expiration date
two weeks
nah let's not risk it i'll get my two
percent elsewhere
from my investment returns
that's just a little financial humor for
you guys
at the end of the day
i didn't get bullied on the court and
you shouldn't get bullied into making
poor financial decisions
oops i gotta go i got a flight in seven
hours it's actually six and a half
previous message was in no way sponsored
or condoned by the united states
treasury department
all right that's our show for tonight
and remember when someone asks you
whether or not crypto has a place in
sports
just say
no
[Applause]
you